today london was hotter than lisbon
welcome relief for those who didn't
choose to travel to portugal
those who did now face uncertainty with
the government advising against holidays
there
and everyone arriving back after tuesday
at 4am
now having to self-isolate for 10 days
i understand that you know we are all
desperate to see the world return to
normal that can only happen through the
domestic unlock
first we all look towards the 21st of
june to see
what can be done and the data and we
simply don't want to put that at risk
through these figures uh as we say as we
say as you've seen in portugal
both the uh doubling of the positivity
rate that we've seen
and also this mutation the so-called
nepal mutation on the so-called indian
variant which could then cause us
problems down the line that's left some
british travelers currently in portugal
frustrated you have to have a system
where either it's open or it's closed
you know i mean there's families
bringing out kids and there's people
booked holidays for a long time
when things constantly change like that
and it's that constant changing of goal
posts that's the frustrating side of
things
we came here because like oh we like
portsmouth greenless that's fine
so yeah it's going to impact my work and
stuff when i get back
noel josephides has been running this
west london travel agency
for 51 years he has never been through a
time as tough as this
it was pretty bad in 1974 when turkey
invaded cyprus
but this this pandemic is never ending
it's been 15 months now
today's announcement portugal is going
to move from the green list
to amber is yet another blow are you
making any money
no none at all
we're losing hundreds of thousands of
pounds we're taking no bookings at
all my staff are spending most of their
time
postponing deferring cancelling
explaining to our clients
what's happening gatwick airport should
be packed today
with half-term holiday makers instead
it's almost deserted
with a tenth of the departures they'd
normally expect
bosses here call today's news bitterly
disappointing
and there is anger and frustration
across the industry
it's not justifiable and it's uh
irrational
the the portugal has a
a similar rate of infections as the uk
and there are many places in the uk who
has much higher rates of
infection and and they also
are tearing up and shredding their own
rule book they said that they were going
to have this watch list where
where country was going to go on to so
people could plan
accordingly but that is not being used
at all in this case
the uk's traffic light system was
supposed to bring clarity
so far it's been closer to chaos the
international travel market
remains gridlocked frozen by a lack of
consumer confidence
with few now willing to take the risks
of going to green countries
in case they turn amber or red in the
future
james was due to fly out to portugal on
saturday but after today's announcement
has cancelled his trip
it was only when we saw the news this
morning that it sort of
we sort of sort of dawned on us you know
there hadn't been anything leading up to
it there hadn't been anyone reporting
that uh portugal's rates had been going
up and it was in jeopardy it was only
when this announcement came today
[Music]
um
it's it is what it is those tempted to
take off abroad
now face a stark choice either go last
minute
or don't go at all joe pike's sky news
gatwick airport